aber was ist eigentlich deutschlands
haltung zu diesem militärschlag vom
letzten wochenende die bundesregierung
fand ihn super aber jetzt nicht so super
dass man direkt mitmachen wollte es
folgt ein satz der angela merkels
lebenswerk geradezu zusammenfasst krieg
ist doof aber aber einfach gar nichts zu
tun ist auch schwierig manchmal einfach
gar nichts zu tun ist auch schwierig
manchmal als wäre ihr das jemals schwer
gefallen meine damen und herren
tatsächlich gibt es ja verdammt gute
gründe bei so einem angriff nicht dabei
zu sein aber man sollte sich dann doch
wenigstens hinterher mit guten
ratschlägen zurückhalten finde ich
deutschland verhält sich im grunde wie
einer der ja der nie mit hilft aber
immer klug scheiß vorsichtig schön auf
dem kreuzheben
ach mensch passt doch auch das schöne
bier das ist deutschland freunde das ist
deutschland das wir gerade gesehen
für alle noch diese ratschläge
über übergangsregierung
und nur mal am rande natürlich werden
wir deutschen als große pazifisten auch
etwas glaubwürdiger wenn wir nicht
weiter im großen stil rüstungsgüter
verticken würden nur eine woche nachdem
die neue gruppe beschlossen hat keine
waffen mehr an länder zu liefern die im
jemen kriegführen mache ich den
fernseher an und die bundesregierung hat
erneut rüstungsexporte nach saudi
arabien genehmigt nach informationen des
zdf handelt es sich um acht
patrouillenboote mit der begründung hat
leider noch die vorgängerregierung
beschlossen ja sie erinnern sich das war
doch diese koalition aus union und spd
mit der mit der jetzigen regierung gar
nicht zu vergleichen
diese welt wird immer gefährlicher die
rüstungsspirale ist zurück und russland
und die usa das ist das fürchterliche
setzen verstärkt auf sogenannte mini
nukes mini moke das sind kleine
atomwaffen aber mit der sprengkraft von
zehn bomben ein absolutes must have
bisher waren nuklearwaffen teuer und
unhandlich aber das ist vorbei
denn jetzt gibt es mini nukes die
handlichen atomwaffen für den alltag
wenn das klo mal wieder verstopft ist
du findest keinen dem urlaub auf den
bund auf passt kein problem
[Musik]
hilft auch bei sodbrennen und
völlegefühl
[Musik]
beliebt
[Applaus]
der traum für mich
das ist ja gar nicht witzig das nukleare
wettrüsten ist tatsächlich zurück und
das sollte uns finde ich noch mehr
beunruhigen als das thema chemie waffen
gibt aber kaum einen außer christian
ehring der fordert die friedensbewegung
der 80er muss zurückkommen und wie sie
sehen eher geht dafür sehr weit
ja ganz genau auf er wirke wir haben
damals vielleicht ausgesehen wie
vollidioten aber wir haben was bewegt
ich sage nur 22 oktober 1983 500.000
menschen demonstrieren in bonn gegen
atomwaffen wo waren sie da eigentlich
wollte aber an dem tag hatte ich ihr
rubik und bis man dann in bonn ist den
ganzen weg aus köln natürlich der
pokerwelt hatte keinen bock auf reden
genau wie die deutschen heute aufwachen
leute es ist im grunde schlimmer als in
den 80ern atomwaffen für die handtasche
was für ein wahnsinn und ein präsident
der solche sachen sagt in dieser sache
müssen wir einfach unberechenbar sein
mit lea waffen sind da die letzte
möglichkeit wenn das militär ins spiel
kommt dann wird nicht diskutiert
erst will ich action und dann wird
geredet erst bomben dann denken gut ist
eine fällt ihm halt auch leichter als
das andere
das abrüstungsabkommen für
mittelstreckenwaffen von 87 steht kurz
vor dem scheitern
amerika und russland beschuldigen sich
gegenseitig ja das ist alles wie früher
er hat angefangen nein der jagd
angefangen nein der und putin tritt nur
noch auf wieso ein bond bösewicht eine
neue atomrakete die jeden punkt der welt
erreichen könne
jenseits aller us raketenschild russland
war und russland bleibt die größte
atommacht aber niemand wollte mit uns
reden niemand wollte uns zuhören hört
jetzt zu
sonst bringen wir euch um die gleiche
kranke logik wie damals wollen wir
wirklich dass die 80er zurückkommen
wollen wir das hatte so schöne haare
gut aber davon mal abgesehen warum
fordern wir nicht den abzug aller
atomwaffen aus deutschland
in büchel in der eifel liegen 20 us
nuklearwaffen können sie machen die
reifen hat sonst nichts
aber deutsche piloten müssten dann im
ernstfall us atomraketen irgendwo im
osten abwerfen
die trägersysteme für die bomben werden
gerade modernisiert mit deutschem
steuergeld also flugzeuge klar ganz
normale bundeswehr tornados
[Musik]
wir haben jetzt modernisiert
120 stark haben sich bei der uno auf den
atomwaffen verbots vertrag geeinigt
deutschland durften ich haben uns die
amis verboten dagegen protestiere ich
jetzt setzt es was ich singe jetzt das
weiche wasser vom bauhof alle strophen
und lasse mich dazu vom schweine system
aus dem studio tragen sie können auch
einfach so gehen nein das wollen die ja
es ist die schwerste mauern ein und sind
wir schwach und sind wir klar wir wollen
[Applaus]